this week we've got messy maps dying
wish and meet plants Oh
all right for our first story and Google
Maps led people to a dirt road that
ended up getting everyone stuck there
because it had been raining previously
and it was just a very bad road to be on
and people are blaming Google Maps for
leading them down this road that many
cars got there yeah like a
three-and-a-half hour pileup pretty much
whoa
yeah them like off the road haha please
wait ways really don't give a [ __ ]
true well wave goes off of Google Maps
to it I heard what do I mean by ways
don't give up they'll tell you to like
drive on the grass waves will get you
there by any means that should be their
tax like all the train tracks on the
sidewalk oh yeah alleys all that through
a kids playground you're getting there
damn yeah yeah wasting this happened in
Colorado and they these people were
trying to get to the airport where it's
like through a shortcut but then they
just got stuck so there was a dirt road
that was like on the maps that typically
people can use but it's not like a paved
road yeah it's not a paved road has been
raining a lot so there were a lot of
like that is weird that it would
reference or that it would tell you to
go through an unpaved road but they go
through they got the kids play around
the stuff too but that's not what I'm
saying like Google that's what it was
crazy that Google Maps picked it up as a
road yeah that's weird so I have seen
this option and I forgot which Maps app
because I is it the [ __ ] button but
no there's an option that says avoid
dirt roads so you can click well we do
know that there are dirt roads that
they're leading you through but nobody
click that and also the Google Maps car
they're also to blame because they have
to drive through all these routes right
to get all the images and all the data
stuff yeah so they're probably want
strolling up like get them through this
one is no you know I mean you know
what's cool about Google Maps not to
like with all the updates like the
parking lot is all mapped out to know if
you're like in a plaza or something and
it's like you got an avid
you're way out to the main road it's all
like oh yeah it's pretty cool finally
yeah it's so often is like go out this
way and I'm like yeah but you don't know
that I'm in the parking that structure
like I'm [ __ ] now I went the wrong way
right it's not like in a structure like
in a tower but it's like like if you're
in a like a strip mall or like yeah yeah
cuz I'll take you to the mall but then
the stores over here but you're on the
opposite side and it doesn't tell you
how to get to the store just took you to
the mall even leaving my house my home
like it's like okay you're you're facing
this way and I'm like no I'm not oh [ __ ]
what do I go like it's so long start
spinning around and [ __ ] yeah yeah
whenever you put an address and it's
just uh all you see is the blue line
like horizontally it doesn't really tell
you like if that's a right until you get
the guy up a little bit you don't mean
then it tell you like go right or left
were [ __ ] is what I'm navigating for my
wife's know like my wife's driving and
then I'm next to her and I got the phone
out and then she's like where do I go
now and I'm like I won't tell me yet cuz
we're we haven't driven on the target
yet yeah then then it updates it and
she's like but she and the moments like
where do I go where do I go that's such
an important position to be in like when
you're the Navigator that is like yeah
you know what I mean like cuz if you
miss it you can like switch apps and be
on Instagram and you miss that oh man
dude if my brother or somebody my family
have a family group text [ __ ] from
Hell where everyone 6,000 messages a day
innit
so yeah it's like I'm navigating for
Nikki and then she looks over and she
sees like something pops up on my screen
she's like you're not doing this you're
[ __ ] what do you do I don't even what
you're doing and I'm like oh I just got
a text from somebody on no but doesn't
Google Maps show you if there's traffic
yeah there should have been like [ __ ]
dead red like don't go this way yeah
yeah I guess I blame humans you can look
and see that the road is wet most people
are saying they're just like use your
best decisions like decision-making
skills you know you can see that there's
a pileup over there yeah not just that
but like the people causing the pileup
you could see that the road is not very
safe for you to drive on with your like
sedan you know there's a couple in the
car there
one person was like we shouldn't be on
the strollers like this what is telling
me and then that when they file yeah
it's too late
look look look not like it big as I told
you some think we're the most smart guy
in traffic ever he's like Jesus in them
some of those roads do it's hard to tell
cuz like it might start dry and flat and
then when you get in you're like [ __ ]
yeah dude sometimes I'm like I'm like
dude like if I get it if we if I tell
Nicky I'm like hey you keep doing this
like to stop breaking so close to
somebody's bumper and then I'm like oh I
hope we get an accident so that I can
turn off oh my god the pity is moments
happen in the relationship he'll get in
a car accident flipping rolling just
looking at it like slow motion ever be
able to use hope we die right now have
you guys ever just follow the GPS and it
takes you to a pretty shady place cuz I
have a sequence where I was taking a
wave yeah and it took me through the
hood like and I was people just staring
at you like what the [ __ ] you're not
from around here the Crypt nearby no so
it was scary because there are these
guys so it was like a lot of homeless
people to it so there was this one guy
that was standing in the middle of the
road and it was a red light so I had to
stop and then he comes up to my car and
he looks like he's about a pound the
window and I was like oh that's when I
say you don't have to obey traffic I
just run red lights just go yeah just
carry if a guy that's looking this way
and this way at the same time is coming
up to you like this you could read that
you could run that read if there's no
cars around you so GP has never failed
you guys know I think for me like I
don't I don't use GPS as the Bible like
I know it's generally taking me and I
think since I've
I have the luxury of growing up in LA I
generally know where things are at like
oh if I'm going to the valley I'm going
like northeast or whatever and I kind of
know where things are not so like as I'm
driving I can see where it's taking me
and I always cross-reference that with
my knowledge of the road no my GPS is
tripping right now there's a lot of
times I'm like this thing's still stupid
I'm gonna just take this way remember
when we were in Hawaii and it made us
make a left on a one-way that was going
this way oh yeah we're like oh I think
I'm just oblivious because sometimes
like like for example I went to a
Kentucky Fried Chicken in the hood but I
didn't know that I was in the hood yeah
and so I just walked in on me you know I
mean in that order to the guy and I'm
like hey I can't hear you really well
because it was through bulletproof
across yes so good man like you got a
really spell it out like like I was like
oh no we don't take cards no okay Kona
Bravo I'm like a cart machine's broken
but yeah and I just walked out with my
bag and just got in my car and drove off
and I will it prove anything you're in
it yeah yeah Mars yeah the bars or the
wording to it they place the food here
and they twist it and you have to take
serve you food in a little box like that
but then my bank has that so I'm like I
guess I'm in the hood I think I live in
the hood moving on to the next story
cops grant said this 93 year old woman's
dying request to be arrested what a king
arrested down yeah hit me down so she's
from England her name is Josie did she
actually commit a crime or she just
wanted to ha they got a grandpa cop to
look like rose from Titanic you have so
many bruises on her wrists no I can't
hold it all people brew so easily hurt
it just keeps falling off of her hands
do could you imagine being in that jail
and you're like serving time there and
this lady's like basically like like a
tourist
yeah so that's what people's response to
the story where they're like wow that
white privilege that's what people are
saying oh wow and then they're just like
how like how are you sorry I'm William
choo-choo how is it white privilege it's
a 98 year old privilege okay it just
sounds like a
privilege is someone that obeyed the law
her whole life well it's uh well sure
but then to these people they see it as
clueless white privilege and then
there's also these like certain memes
that say like collective black confusion
and then stairs and sista I thought
there oh there was like jail tour stuff
though and that's not you know she
wanted be like arrested arrested so this
is like some responses Oh people that go
to prison or like jail that they didn't
commit like they're innocent but yet
they're still treated very poorly but
for her she was just given like you know
the red carpet treat
like a jail yeah she wanted to be an
interrogation room so she wasn't
interrogation where she wanted to see a
jail cell but they they were like no you
can't do that oh I saw work at a prison
as a CEO and there was a prison um there
is a in the prison I was at there's like
four different buildings and one of the
buildings is like they say is actually
haunted but it was like one of the first
prisons and Texas type of things and
that that is like a museum type of thing
so you can see the keys that they had oh
yeah but they don't arrest you to go
there yeah they should that's sick as a
like a ticket like you can you can buy
the membership and get arrested get the
whole trip there spend a night in jail
damn whole experience yeah you crazy
okay they're saying though for this old
lady she her whole family members there
were like role-playing that they were
accusing her of robbing a grocery store
that's [ __ ] weird
she's got little kinks man she's cute
you stole the asparagus I know you do
how long has she been wanting this
because she's old but it's like was it a
new thing for her I don't know maybe
she's so old that she's done everything
so now she's like you know what I I
haven't been a jailer yet maybe she
murdered someone and she's like whoa if
they caught me this is what it would
feel like oh just that much of a
gangster much as I put it in their face
yeah the system has failed me a lot
because I've done so many crimes and
never been caught for it so I just want
to know what it feels like yeah she's
trolling right now she's doing a bit
dude so how long did you work at a jail
for two years
was it County or illustrator prison was
the execution unit so you were with
lifers then yeah but they don't have
they have but they have actually they
actually have the death sentence in
Texas right yeah yes the injection is it
true that that gets nicer facilities
when you're on death row no I don't I
don't think so exactly I was a
corrections officer so I was just 18 you
just need to be 18 and have a high
school because killer money so what you
end up doing so I was I would work out
all the cell blocks like any Cell Block
in the prison uh I never seen an
execution happen but I've definitely
worked while the execution was happening
it was like they start they actually put
the first needle in at 6:00 and then by
6:30 they're already out there yeah so
what is your job just totally shut the
[ __ ] up all day
oh yes I mean it's pretty much like it
was like a daycare for adults yeah like
you you let them know when it's
lunchtime not picking her ass yeah they
don't they don't come and try to [ __ ]
with you or anything like that cuz
they're like they see this young guy
yeah oh you're sure yeah hell yeah
especially like it's like an alpha male
contest on a puff their chest hello
young I'm my 18 year old and you got you
know inmates they're like twice my age
twice my size and they're just like I
got to listen to this debate do they
lick their lips at you like mmm-hmm then
call me Chris Brown inmate there's an
inmate of that uh whenever there's count
time you have to wake them up because
they have to show you their ID
yeah perfect they could actually fake
like put pillows in their thing they can
already be escaped so that's why you
have to wake them up so like that you're
still in yourself yeah so I wake that
I'm like you know do my day this dudes
asleep but he's like trying to troll me
so like a oh man will so like let me
show you come see your ID
and he's like don't wake me up
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you're good you're good
yeah they got me with that one cute joke
for a death sentence
dude like he's killed like 20 people
he's still goofing around we'll see
that's another thing too like we have
the option to see what they did but it's
always recommended like in even the
academy they're like don't look at what
they did in the prison because if you
find out that this nice ass inmate that
says good morning to you every single
day is a child molester
then you're gonna treat them differently
you know I'm saying you're gonna start
seeing people differently you're gonna
mean treat them all like child molesters
just what they should do yeah so it's
like if there's also a thing of like you
know you can't be too nice to image you
know tell they may thank you or you know
you'll say yes sir good they try to get
it in with you yeah exactly like if they
offer you a coke whatever or yeah it's
all it's all games with inmates that's
it yeah it's all a game leverage damn
that's crazy
yeah first three months you got to be
Stern you got to be a cop as they say
like a Robocop than just like really you
know that's why I had to do that I'm 18
you know voice still cracker and just
like Clark you know like yeah late pre
booty wait very like that lady man
that's scary
yeah the only thing I want to do is walk
by the jail cell with the baton and go
man checking checking the rows and
seeing you know making sure they're not
doing anything like contraband or you
know some a lot of image though they'll
put their mirror out to see like if
you're if you're gonna be coming if
you're walking up if you see that you
gotta let them know put that mirror back
in or because another in some inmates if
it's a lady correction officer a lady
bosses they say they'll want to like
masturbate on her oh they'll like
they'll see if she's like walking up and
they like with their dick out and start
like jacking off so they did that they
they would like jizz on ya dick here
delhi - huh yeah they'll try it to try
to stick their dick out and shoot it at
her yeah they'll try to try to
yeah they're so deprived probably well I
mean I hate Jewish but we got to talk
about the last article for we can
scramble so the last article we have is
that Arby's has created a meat scible
like a fake meat sandwich at Arby's no
so instead of fake me that the fake
vegetable made out of meat it's a merit
uh-oh
Arby's is like [ __ ] you Beyond yeah
that'll be on [ __ ] you Wow yes the merit
looks like it's made out of Turkey this
buddy
[ __ ] with my mind too much so I'm
gonna show you guys a video clip of how
I know what carrots tastes like and I'm
gonna taste Turkey that's weak what if
it tastes like care about the marinade
and carrots juice yeah
[Music]
stupid veggie for me got too much oh
[Music]
it's one piece plastic wrap oh that's
kind of cool yeah I bet it tastes like
[ __ ] though
it's turkey breast with carrot juice
powder nothing although here foods
carrot flavor to anything the meat
courses are they have that though they
haven't announced that this is gonna go
out to the public this is just one of
those like culinary innovation things in
their kitchen that they create RVs know
if you already don't [ __ ] with our last
time you in our be any time I get a
chance to okay so if I ever if we ever
had like meetings in in Hollywood you
have to exit sunset or Hollywood you go
to the big hat I always go there and I
grab something won't [ __ ] [ __ ] I've
been with you for [ __ ] almost 11
years now we've all I've only seen you
eat there twice there's not that many
Arby's in it is okay Julia to meetings
yeah a lot of RVs and elevations but
it's road trip food you always see it
when you roadtrip it's like I just
recently tried Arby's for the first time
in my life and you loved it it was
pretty good but I felt so bad about
myself why cuz there's just so unhealthy
which one did you get I got the white
guilty sex for like cheddar that's
pretty good roast beef or one of those
the bread was so good high school it was
five for five dollars I remember that
what yeah in high school the sweet o's
dude I love the radicals all the [ __ ]
time and you've never got close down oh
right yeah if I were Jesse just like
shoes she loves Arby's to she's like
yeah it's [ __ ] good it does he's
really good I go
and my body's just like I hate you the
horseradish sauce is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'd force riders yeah bro sauces you
like horseradish [ __ ] no that ruins a
whole meal even if it touches what about
what you eat prime rib you don't get it
with the horseradish no I'm good what
about shrimp cocktail
I hate those flavors you gotta add
horseradish with the shrimp cocktails no
it's too strong it's like don't put that
much you don't like wasabi a little bit
on no I don't do a sock spicy anything
like you know hot sauce but like
horseradish
it's a different kind of spice yeah
that's true actually it all three like
clears my sinuses no spice I like that
call it battery acid flavor
Bobby horseradish tartar sauce
um one night you said cocktail sauce oh
yeah battery acid flavor yeah no I can't
do it I like it with me horseradish is
just it's pretty good it is good you
need horseradish on that [ __ ] what's the
white sauce come like that similar the
similar one is that worse radish sour
cream
yes that's it's white horseradish tartar
tartar has like the little pickles in it
looks like relish or something to our
association with my fish Asian mustard
is pretty I love Asian Esther play the
yellow one
yeah so good balance it's an Asian thing
right it's the only Asian thing would
you guys put any of those sauces on this
merit [ __ ] no no I wouldn't even eat
that period yeah first of all it's taped
it's turkey breast I know [ __ ] that
turkey bread you need a lot of seasoning
yeah I can't tell you the last time I
ate anything without hot sauce I am a
hot sauce guy I put tobacco screen to
Tapatio no no no no no not desserts but
every all my meals it's all covered in
that you ever had spicy ice cream though
no that's the thing what is it I don't
know what it is but I heard that that's
the thing you know what tripped me out
of when you guys had to get together and
Vince brought those spicy chocolate
cookies that was kind of weird
it was pretty good but then as you eat
the cookie I got spicier and spicier
like a handsome
yeah cuz he ate it and what do you start
doing it sorta like uh he didn't know
what was a spicy chocolate that was you
trying to troll I remember that no no it
made sense because it was that was in
Moline like it was like something it
made sense while I was spicy but then I
see
[Music]